i can't do it
i can't
not work on a feature in hazel so i'm
supposed to be working on like qa stuff
you know trying to fix hazel that was
the last video that came out a couple
days ago but the thing is tim's working
on a scene
in hazel to demonstrate
our new animation system
and
he like
chucked some birds up in the air and
they're just kind of like there's like a
few there's like three you know and
they're just like traveling on these
paths and
it's fine
but i was like
why don't we add like a thousand of them
why don't we add like a thousand of them
and then have like some kind of flocking
behavior
or moths we could add moths it would be
cool to have like a lot of them and if
they could kind of you know have a basic
flocking ai or something so that they
can you know look all nice there so i
was like
let's do it now was it the most
responsible choice no because again i
should be working on making hazel stable
with what we have right now
and yet here i am so i thought i would
take you guys along with me on this
little flocking adventure
it's
like about noon right now i'm only
giving myself today to do this because
there's no way
that i can afford to spend any more time
on this and what i would like to do is
basically take a look at sebastian's
boyd's video that he made along with the
unity source code take a look at that
project and see if i can just join that
and just
make it work in hazel there are going to
be some things api wise that hazel
doesn't support which i'm going to have
to add as well
but that's kind of how hazel grows right
we try and make stuff and then we see oh
like for example we have no way to run a
compute shader from c sharp we just
don't have that functionality so let's
add that in now and over time we get
something that has more of a complete
picture it's always nice when you work
on kind of a smaller engine because your
needs your actual projects
they drive the features that get
implemented rather than arbitrarily
being like oh i want this i want that
and then you'll be working for the rest
of your life and
there won't be much reward since you're
not actually making anything you're just
working on the features so yeah
not much time
but let's see if we can basically
recreate sebastian's like flocking demo
inside our hazel animation demo okay so
this is the repository for a much better
implemented and performant version you
have a look at this now this is way too
complicated like there's just too much
stuff here i don't really care about
this this is just for a simple animation
demo this is basically just what i need
so i think we're going to go ahead and
take a look at this quickly
scripts yeah this is this looks pretty
simple let's just clone this set this up
i'm going to run it in unity first just
to see if it even works
and what it looks like i guess okay so
here we have it working in unity a few
of them are escaping that's all right
though looks like we have like these
kind of walls and obstacles and they're
able to steer around them which is great
and there's a lot of them and they look
pretty nice
so obviously we're gonna replace like
the models with birds that tim made and
when i say we're going to replace the
models it sounds like we're going to go
into this unity project and do stuff
we're obviously not because we have to
put this into hazel but this is going to
be like our little starting point so i
want to quickly take a look at what the
scene is even made out of so we've got
main camera directional light level
which i'm assuming is just like yeah so
level is like all of this stuff
um and then we've got void manager
which
has a script
called boyd manager and then spawner
spawner prefab here
which has a bunch of settings and
the spawner script so let's go ahead and
like open
the void manager script okay so taking a
look at
the scripts
yeah so see we have like this
compute dispatch right which we
obviously have compute shaders in hazel
because we use them like for a number of
things but
we
we we don't have any kind of like c
sharp api for that if you want a
computer you're kind of expected to
write it natively in c plus plus
which is fine like what we could do for
this if we wanted to
is we could just like
basically write a function
you know called like
process voids or something and have this
be a native function so we can call from
c sharp back into c plus plus that's
really easy to do with hazel
because like
obviously we have the full cpl plus
source code for the engine so we can
just literally write a function have it
do whatever we want in c plus plus and
just call it from c sharp but i don't
really want to do that because i kind of
want to use this as an excuse
to
create this kind of api so i want to be
able to here's the compute shader it's
not very big right i want to kind of use
this as an excuse to add this feature to
hazel to be able to
basically like grab this compute shader
somehow um and then set like a bunch of
uh data into that compute shader and
then just dispatch it and then i guess
retrieve the data that we'll write into
this buffer
so we don't have anything like that so
we need some kind of compute shader api
i guess explosions of c sharp and then a
compute buff like i can take some
shortcuts
because this is a very specific use case
but i'll try and make it as generalized
as i can so that's one thing that i'm
seeing here
that we'll need to add okay so awake so
in hazel we have a function called
oncreate obviously that will be
that will be called at the beginning
when the entity gets instantiated and
then that will um go ahead and
instantiate the a bunch of like boyd
prefabs that should be pretty
standard oh okay so this uses a physics
sphere cast which we don't have in hazel
so we're probably gonna have to look at
the nvidia physx
api and see if we can do some kind of
geometry sweep probably with a sphere
and then use that as like a scene query
to get the data back so we'll have to
pro that'll
i don't imagine that'll be too much work
but yeah that's like that's pretty
that's pretty much it this is a lovely
little project i mean it's so small
let's have a quick look at the computer
really straightforward obviously we're
just in parallel over 1024 kind of uh
threat groups work groups over here
we're just going to do some math on the
boys it was time to get down and do some
work so i decided to condense this into
kind of a time lapse it took about two
hours also to get all of this working i
do have the full recording i've
contemplated posting it somewhere maybe
someone will enjoy that kind of content
maybe i'll put it up as an exclusive
video for patreons if you guys are
interested in seeing that then
definitely let me know in the comments
below i actually decided not to
implement the whole compute shader thing
i took the compute shader and just wrote
it in the c sharp code the reason being
is for this animation demo like we
really only needed like maybe 20 to 30
birds max and that's definitely not
enough to warrant using a computer
shader it performed just fine in c-sharp
in the future though i'd love to come
back to this example and do it with like
thousands in a computer shader and now
that we have a basic demo let's hop on
over to tim's computer to try and
integrate it with the animation scene
yeah that's kind of cool all right so
flocking example
beautiful
beautiful
so how do we take this and plop it into
your scene let's do it
animation demo yeah
all right so what are you what's your
current bird setup oh yeah the mesh
that's broken
that's a bad tim
yeah so like that because it also
doesn't have a skeleton or something no
it has a skeleton um all right i
honestly i don't
know what it's like controls now oh
maybe that's might be
why ah oh no
no it's not wrong that tail is that's
the that's a tail that's supposed to be
back there
oh
yeah you see because it goes inside of
it so bad nah i just want to like delete
all the regenerator that's that's the
problem that actually should be it
like let's just hit play
oh
all right
so they're obviously not facing the
right way but they have reached the
blimp
but it doesn't have a collider problem
is tim it's actually kind of your fault
i think
surprisingly because what you've done
yes this is the tail so it does make
sense that it's it's it is the wrong way
around yeah
so flip the bit
because the card is like the thing is
obviously set up to
whatever forward is the annoying thing
is
and i basically re-import this no
that's the annoying that's the annoying
thing like the meshes is fine you can
just right click on the skeleton but the
skeleton you have to delete and create a
new one or just you know that's it's in
tim's issues okay if anybody's ever read
that but yeah frankly i don't think
anybody has all right attack the blimp
go
my minions
oh
yeah thank you very cool you're working
out all right
that's great
it looks disgusting it looks horrible
but check it out they need to be faster
can move faster the birds oh they're
penetrating the
fin
oh that's kind of cool
they're
no they'll come back right
they always do yeah
yeah look oh that's sick
yeah now they actually look like birds
yeah when they just don't really care
oh
they're sweeping into the blade
that's pretty cool that is kind of sick
if their animations were offset as well
yeah i don't think there's a way to do
that yeah and
no wait actually zero x
added something recently they're coming
down
swooping it's the magpies bro but look
they're kind of going up again which is
kind of cool but to be honest it's kind
of hard to tell that's shipped
it's like kind of a nice sun city kind
of thing yeah that's cute that also by
the way
let's not talk about going to talk about
the elephant in the room it's a sunset
it's a nice sunset it's so bright look
how bright it is here
it's too bright that's it
hope you guys enjoyed the video not much
of an outro here just wanted to say
thank you for watching let me know what
you think of this kind of format it's
kind of
me trying to make an effort to show
more of what we do here i've kind of
been digging this raw format like
there's no music anywhere if you noticed
which i think kind of contributes to
the uniqueness maybe of these videos if
you want to play around with this little
flocking demo that i've made inside
hazel then i've pushed it onto the dev
branch inside the sandbox project it's a
little scene called flocking if you
don't have access to hazel that you can
get access by supporting the project on
patreon.com the churno hoping to do more
of these kinds of videos in the future
i'll see you guys next time goodbye